i'm esther pavitsky is that important
i think i'm friends with whitney
cummings i actually have no idea if
we're friends or not but she did let me
come to her house and told me i can just
go through her bathroom when i feel like
all the secrets are here and i'm ready
to find them out i need to know like
what is her makeup her skincare
this is going to be embarrassing but you
know what i'm unapologetic that's my
brand i don't care
i would love nothing more than to
embarrass whitney company i feel like
there was this thing where like anyone
on camera would like pretend they didn't
do anything
to their skin it was like oh no i just
wear sunscreen and
i walk my dog and like i play with my
kids yes i just like
like sing like we have like like
bonfires and i get some coconut oil and
i make my own masks
fuck out of here fuck you oh wait you're
going there first oh no should i not you
know what
i was great she's going to hair basket
straight to the root spray which sprays
out the grays
because i get grays because i'm in a
male-dominated business and all my
friends are predators and it makes me
have gray hair
it would be right there you do that to
like fill it in
i'm just showing like what they would
fill in on the show yeah
oh my gosh that's so cold
what the fuck that is throw that away
you know what you guys just saw the
first moment of me going like oh no
she's gonna find that thing and i just
owned it
what is this what colostrum do you guys
know what colostrum is
because i know oh my god placenta
oh so she's a witch colostrum is breast
milk
gotta do what you gotta do why do you
have this in the spot i love this
the smell do you know what this is pink
sugar how do you know this because this
is like really popular at sephora it
smells like strippers it's great
everyone puts their makeup on so fucking
weird everyone's got their own weird
shit like this
when you put on lipstick do you move the
lipstick or do you move your lips i move
my lips
that's weird now that is weird but i'll
move my head
to match that is so scary to watch so
you do this
of course i do do you go like this
yeah you're just like
oh so you move your hand try to do it
just keep that still and just move your
lips
that is so weird it's like sexual there
you know what that is
no you don't know what that is is that
for your vagina what is this
guess is it for your butt crack you put
it here when you sleep
so that when you do this you don't get
wrinkles on your chest
these are the trade secrets that i'm
here for today
it also helps build your immune system
because it's so fucking disgusting
okay no this is not a secret so everyone
knows my face
is lubed up and grapeseed oil is the
number one thing that i put on my
face but this is my main vat of it this
is tomato seed oil dude i'm telling you
i'm obsessed with this milk moisturizer
because it's rapeseed
it's grape seed oil this is an oil that
looks like
semen that doesn't look like semen to me
i just learned a lot about your fiance
but it's like a white oil by lila b
isn't that good and i put that under my
eyes and just like lube it on
lube for my vagina is it really yes
wait don't i don't even really use it i
just love the bottle
it feels exactly like what's in my
underwear at the end of the day taking
makeup
off the first thing i do grapeseed oil
all over my face
and i let it like dissolve for a second
and then i'll do
i haven't been wearing a ton of eye
makeup lately but i'll use the drunk
elephant
it's like a bomb i have that it's like a
makeup removing balm
also says so much about the way i use it
but i do this and i put it on my eye
makeup and let it like set for a minute
this is a multiple cleansing layer
there's an oil layer
a bomb layer bomb layer and then stay
here
big gift well then once you have
all that on you have to put on
headphones so that when you lay down
your face doesn't touch the pillow
because then all the work you just did
and all those nice products that you put
on are just gonna wipe off under your
pillow
that's cool yeah what nars orgasm always
never had an actual orgasm but i do have
the blood
this is my number one beauty product
like exfoliate my
whole body and then i'll do it with like
an oil this is a rose oil which you
would hate
and then grape seed oil and i'll just
fucking go
like meth head crazy look at this
use this exfoliator this is truly the
greatest exfoliator on the planet
it's because they're so small tiny grain
the grains
are so small it's like a sexual
experience
forget all this fucking fancy shit tiger
bomb this
is tell me what you use it for truly the
best chin on the planet
so i have a shoulder injury i just like
rub it on there if it ever hurts or like
the back of my neck or if i get a
migraine i'll do it in my temples and on
my forehead
and sometimes i'll put it is it like a
menthol thing yes i get dandruff
i get like itchy scalp is that not sexy
to say do you get the thing where when
you scratch your head it just starts
snowing
no this is actually an amazing oil
mother special blend it's for
stretch marks but i use it all the time
everywhere this looks like a summer's
eve like a 70s product that was made for
women
back when like women were not equal if
you could
take anything you wanted no questions
asked
i already know exactly you get to have
whatever you want
i get a saw i take this bandage out it's
kind of no
question what i want really nothing let
me see if i can guess yeah i guess
is it the snake earrings
what is her deal if i'm really allowed
to take something expensive i would take
the bittner's daughter
should she do it should she do it all
right i'm taking business
yeah so the biggest takeaways for me
today are
the order in which you're putting your
creams on and it's
toner serum moisturizer oil
you're not ashamed that you use root
spray anymore no we really worked
through that
you validated a lot of the things that i
thought were crazy like using like grape
seed oil and stuff that's like ten
dollars can be just as valuable a
product as
one that's like a hundred dollars i am
still gonna take the hundred dollar one
yeah okay
didn't talk yet